[Música]
em 2015 o cozinheiro do bem furtado
fighters surgiu da necessidade gritante
das ruas de porto alegre é possível com
o mínimo de sensibilidade não vê o
aumento gritante da população em
situação de rua e eu não podia deixar
isso passar de uma forma invisível como
essa população
um dia estava adaptada de um programa e
eu vi me mil músicos que tinham se
juntado para chamar a atenção de uma
banda assim poxa porque não consigo como
cozinheiro juntar mil pessoas para
cozinhar para quem tem fome
participando de um reality show e eu
pensei que poderia usar daquilo para
poder atingir as pessoas
gravei um vídeo de uma forma
despretensiosa do nível
outro dia eu acordei tinha finalizado o
vídeo e as pessoas começaram a falar que
a gente faça
nós tínhamos combinado num ponto de
cozinhar para as pessoas mas no dia
choveu muito
eu nunca mais vou esquecer do dia 5 de
setembro de 2015 um sábado onde o evento
já tinha sido cancelado e eu falei eu
vou para lá as pessoas têm fome um dia
de chuva e frio elas sentem mais fome
ainda não acordei minha esposa eu falei
assim daqui a pouco volta peguei um
fogareiro peguei uma sacola
entrei um carro e fui para baixo do
viaduto da conceição em porto alegre
nesse dia
eu e mais três amigos servimos comida
para 70 pessoas
voltei pra casa contei que tinha sido
lindo aquilo me tocou muito coração
só que eu não tinha pretensão de seguir
com o projeto que tinha um cara que já
fazia o almoço no sábado aí ele falou
assim em julho para 12 anos aqui fazendo
isso aqui embaixo e eu não consegui
servir mais do que nunca o almoço vem
aqui no primeiro dia já serviu 70 pra
frente tudo contigo meu galo
ai ai eu cheguei em casa de novo fazer
isso porque depois não vai dar pra
voltar atrás eu tinha conhecido uma
palavrinha de origem africana
alguns falam significa que nós somos
sou quem sou porque somos todos nós é a
consciência do espírito coletivo
entender que eu não posso ficar no
conforto do seu lar bem arrumadinho quem
tinha outras pessoas estão na rua
passando necessidade
seja na rua ou seja numa aldeia seja
onde for no albergue uma creche numa
comunidade e isso me moveu o segundo
final de semana nós somos mais servimos
120 almoço e eu resolvi criar uma página
movimentar melhor isso aí
no terceiro não servimos 750 almoço no
quarto agente serviu 1.400 almoço
aí o grupo já tinha crescido nós já
tínhamos uma média de uns 30 voluntários
hoje nós somos 300 300 voluntários
quem dá parece um número grande mas são
poucos voluntários porque hoje porto
alegre tem mais de 7 mil pessoas em
situação de rua e vulnerabilidade
os números são gritantes segundo dados
da luva spm último ano cresceu esse
número 63 por cento gente eu estou
falando de porto alegre
estou falando de mim ainda
a gente vai chegar lá a gente planta
ideia a gente plantou essa idéia e as
pessoas começaram a falar julho é louco
é que tá querendo fazer negócios e
comida pra galera na outra um monte de
vagabundos não existem pessoas muito é
isso
o ubuntu e saber que somos quem somos
porque somos todos nós independente de
classe independente de cor independente
de credo
o cozinheiro do bem hoje alguns
coletivos que mais ajuda a pessoas em
situação de rua no brasil por não ter
ligação política nem religiosa por
entender que a gente consegue levar amor
e carinho às pessoas através do alimento
alimento usado com uma ponte dentro
disso a gente conseguisse resgatar uma
pessoa seria uma vitória a gente já
resgatou mais de 40
nesses quase três anos a semente foi
plantada hoje eu tenho uma filha minha
que é líder de uma das ações aqui
isso pra mim é motivo de orgulho porque
é esse ensinamento essa herança que eu
quero deixar pra minha filha e é esse
pensamento que eu quero trazer à
reflexão de repensar para as próximas
gerações
se eu vou ver o fim da fome eu não sei
talvez não pode ser clichê mas a semente
foi plantada e uma coisa eu tenho muito
orgulho que enquanto nós temos uma ação
nossa em porto alegre
nenhuma das pessoas que estão numa ação
nossa precisa meter a mão em uma lata de
lixo pra comer
isso para nós é a grande vitória hoje é
sábado a animação
embaixo do viaduto da conceição hoje nós
vamos servir mais mil almoços com
certeza amanhã nós temos mais duas
porque hoje o cozinheiro do bem tem
cinco ações semanais que distribui 15
toneladas de comida por mês para as
pessoas em situação de rua de porto
alegre
a gente ainda vai chegar em sete ações
controlando a fome aqui
aí vai ter comida gostosa quem tinha um
abraço carinho e desejo de bom apetite
para cada pessoa que estiverem na fila
isso é amor
é difícil ver um cara desse tamanho e
chorando mas ray obrigado pai mãe saiu
brigado mas voltando eu trago essa
reflexão e isso me fez repensar e no ano
de 2016 quando chegava como tiago falou
eu decidi vender o restaurante não tinha
aquele sonho de todo o chefe de cozinha
de trabalhar no restaurante estrelado de
ter participado como participei de um
mero de show isso era minha missão
eu não acho errado mas entendendo com um
quarto da comida que vai pro lixo no
mundo nós conseguiremos acabar com a
fome mundial sabendo que 60% do que é
produzido vai para o lixo e que de 60% e
70% se perde no transporte do campo até
a cidade e 30 por cento da comida se
perde dos nossos pratos das nossas
geladeiras na sobra dos nossos
geladeiras dos nossos pratos quando a
gente faz um restaurante chegue serve um
pouquinho além da conta quando a gente
vai numa feira e não compra uma fruta
porque ela da estradinha essa frutinha a
gente poderia ajudar a acabar com a fome
no mundo
estou falando de uma consciência de
espírito coletivo eu estou falando de
prestar atenção nos detalhes e é isso
que a gente faça através disso a gente
consegue construir histórias como a da
crise à crise eu conheci no primeiro dia
de ação do cozinheiro do bem
ela chegou para me abraçar e agradecer
pelo prato de comida que ela estava
recebendo ea crise nesse dia falou legal
eu queria ser cozinheiro queria
trabalhar com gastronomia contou
eu falei cara fica aqui a gente conversa
só que ela estava um pouco alterada
neste dia e ela saiu e depois eu fui
encontrar cristo um ano depois quando
ela saiu da cadeia onde ela havia
perdido a filha dela e ela me abraçou e
falou se eu tivesse ouvido aquele dia
talvez a história tivesse do outro eu
falei calma que nunca é tarde pra gente
recomeçar a crise
o dia da mulher o ano de 2016
a loja é ao nosso levamos ela por um
hispano pintamos o cabelo dela e nesse
dia a gente deu a notícia que ela
estaria empregado e ela começou a
trabalhar numa fábrica de trufas e ela
me mandou a foto da gente né ai primeiro
gordinha que há uma linha coraçãozinho
ar ela é sensacional
a criança conseguiu realizar alguns
sonhos dela e um dead sonhos foi fazer
um churrasco que ela fazia queria fazer
aniversário de 15 anos da filha dela que
ela conseguiu reaver a guarda
além disso cozinheiros do bem hoje
auxilia mais cinco instituições em porto
alegre que nós adotamos em parceria com
nosso amigo cláudio da rocha chica duas
aldeias duas aldeias no cantagalo e aí a
gente coloca a cabeça para pensar e
entende que quando a gente fala de
necessidade a gente está falando não só
das pessoas que estão nas ruas mas
muitas vezes as pessoas que estão no
entorno das ruas e muitas vezes as
pessoas que estão do nosso lado dentro
do próprio projeto porque eu tenho
certeza que hoje cozinheiro do bem faz
muito mais bem as pessoas que participam
do coletivo e quer para as pessoas que
são assistidas
mas hoje nós já assistimos três mil
pessoas por semana em porto alegre
isso é uma grande vitória além disso nós
auxiliamos as cinco instituições que a
gente distribui comida carinho conversa
braço no abraço gigante na
então a galera gosta a troca um olhar no
olho
sentir que são pessoas são seres humanos
como nós olhar de uma maneira entender
que aquela pessoa que está ali
às vezes ela tá fedendo porque eu não
tenho uma máquina para lavar roupa dela
e ela assume que é porque ela não tem
uma cama pra deitar e ela tá com o
sapato desgastado que deu para ela na
semana passada porque ela caminha semana
inteira e ela não pode parar
uma das nossas ações
somos simpsons hoje em um dia que eu
criei o coletivo eu sonhei com o mapa
mundi eu acordei assim falando patrícia
olha aqui pra mim olha aqui ela falava
olha o que eu falei olha o mapa olha o
mapa era o mapa mundi um monte de
luzinhas piscando e era o que eu
enxergava no meu sonho
várias luzes do cozinheiro do bem
espalhado pelo mundo inteiro
eu não estou fazendo isso aqui como um
convite trazendo uma reflexão para vocês
pensarem se vocês abrirem a porta das
casas de você andar em 50 metros por um
lado 50 metros para o outro vai ter
alguém com necessidade
precisando de uma ajuda imagina uma
palavra uma ajuda um carinho é um
conforto eu cozinho porque eu sou
cozinheiro
se você é músico enfim é tocar
se você é bailarina o cinedança
aproveitar e anuncia também o carinho
com crianças os idosos que têm aumentado
nesses últimos anos o número de idosos e
de crianças nos últimos anos tem
crescido de uma forma absurda pessoas
que colaboraram durante sua vida toda a
sociedade e não sabem como pedir esmola
não sabem como pedir ajuda mas o olhar
das pessoas falámos olha agora para quem
está do outro lado
com certeza essa pessoa está querendo
dizer alguma coisa com você
ria uma criança fantástica que me
ensinou que eu não preciso ser perfeito
para ajudar alguém não preciso ser um
santo para ajudar o próximo eu só
preciso entender tanto tempo do mundo
o egoísmo que nós tivemos é a prova de
que não foi da forma que a gente quer
criar e construir o futuro que nós
queremos própria daqui pra frente dos
nossos filhos mais amor mais carinho
amor e carinho amor e carinho amor
carinho com paixão compreensão repitam
as palavras sempre sempre mundo lá fora
gritando mundo lá fora grita
e ele grita por pessoas como vocês
fizeram hoje aqui para refletir para
assistir pra entender eu tenho certeza
que o coração de cada um aqui está
pronto para ajudar
cozinheiros do bem procura levar mais do
que alimento
nesse dia nós servimos 400 pizza embaixo
de um viaduto
fornecemos as pitas na hora do nosso
estilo napolitano é essa que vocês fazem
as melhores pizzarias porque o
cozinheiro do bem servir comida com
qualidade
nós servimos comida com qualidade nós
nos preocupamos nós montamos uma
verdadeira estrutura de restaurante no
meio da rua
o fogão industrial uma ilha com uma
brigada de cozinha que organiza tudo e
cada pessoa que chega lá na ponta da
fila recebe um bom apetite se quiser
repetir volte e traga por favor a
marmita com aquela no lixo
existem histórias assim como das pessoas
essa foto representa muito porque esse
cara foi a segunda ação que ele comeu
sete vezes porque às vezes o nosso prato
até o talo como eles dizem lá em ato a
única refeição digna que eles têm
durante a semana a semana sem comer nada
catando comida no lixo os olhares paulo
as pessoas precisam de carinho as
pessoas precisam de atenção e isso vale
muito mais do que qualquer coisa dela um
país no futuro digno de respeito onde
cor não vai mais a diferença onde o que
tem dentro da sua carteira não vai fazer
diferença onde a roupa que tivesse não
vai fazer diferença
acho que está na hora de a gente começar
dentro de nós mesmos e buscarmos isso
para o futuro
hoje eu sou feliz
hoje sou feliz porque semana passada nós
servimos 2.500 almoço
hoje nós temos ação amanhã na
organização
amanhã vou estar mais feliz ainda porque
amanhã nós vamos servir mais comedidos
feliz de verdade eu voltar no dia que
não tiver mais nenhuma pessoa na fila
nesse dia eu vou poder dizer que a fome
acabou
até lá a gente segue muito obrigado
[Aplausos]